what would you buy with 50 billion
pounds that's not a question most of us
get to ask ourselves very often except
Nick that is obviously but that's
precisely what the EU will be able to do
after the government agree to up their
offer of a brexit divorce bill in the
hope it will unlock trade talks next
month as a brexit ear I am of course
outraged by this but logically to
achieve the best outcome there's no
other option it's what we have to do
what I'm most angry about is the
childish behavior of politicians here
and in Europe when it comes to brexit
the EU is trying to punish us saying we
can't even talk about trade until we've
given them enough money and MPs here
especially labor and know better they
are making life difficult for this
government just to score points and I am
so tired and bored of all the squabbling
around brexit politicians need to grow
up and do their jobs that's what they
are paid for we've decided we verted so
please let's just get on with it like
you I'm bored with all the squabbling
and as you know I'm an ardent leaver but
I am in the can desn't was raged at the
idea that we should be paying 50 billion
quid to leave the EU we didn't vote for
this surrender this is sickening
appeasement on a grand scale you know
Teresa Way said No Deal is a bad deal
this is a terrible deal and people will
quite rightly go bananas it on this
we've gone from Boris saying and you
know go whistle 250 billion quid which i
think is actually that's not being
potentially but you know if they're
knowing a lot the way they'll be
negotiating so far that will probably
under pay more and you know it's you
know yes we should pay what we
contractually Oh but we should not pay
to tray you know trade is not an act of
generosity this we are going to be doing
this and you know people you know last
week that I think it was a World Bank
published a paper saying if if we had to
walk away without a deal what would
happen is in if we had to go to world
trade rules with the 27 different
countries they said the worst case
is that our trade with the EU would go
down by just 2% so it's not it's not
it's not gonna be catastrophic but the
idea that we have to pay to trader them
is chronic pay what we owe but what we
are was not 50 but if it is 50 billion
if it's decided because don't forget all
that's happened now is we've agreed a
framework by which we will calculate
this and if you've got liabilities you
will also have assets as well so we
don't know we don't know what's that
monies but if that amount is 50 billion
contractually that we are would you be
comfortable with that I don't believe it
is if nobody if it is but I don't
believe it but let's just say we don't
know we don't know what the amount is
but if it is decided in determined is 15
we don't actually have to pay anything
actually we're being the good guys
saying that we will pay up to the end of
the budget in 2019 we don't actually
have to do that but we do have common
idea we're gonna cook we're gonna commit
50 billion quid is outrageous I don't
know why I'm laughing cuz it's not
really funny not funny you know I mean
you talk about bad deal for me the bad
deal and I'm also upset about 50 billion
and the reason I'm upset is that we are
going to have to pay predictably in my
view a huge amount of money to leave an
organization which has benefited us it
is it is a catastrophic a bad deal but
it was always foreseeable and that's
what upsets me that people voted brexit
I think not understanding the cost and
Carol I know you don't like me about
money none of us do but it was we were
always gonna have to pay to leave and
that's why we don't um how you say what
people voted leave on the assumption
that rather than us paying 50 billion
we're gonna get 350 million a week back
well so soon into their coffers that and
as we even saw from the budget which I
think was last week well that feels like
a lifetime ago the NHS is getting 2.7
billion but they're not just in order
for us to achieve brexit you know the
customs and the lorry parks and all rest
of it they need another three billion so
brexit is actually gonna cost an
enormous amount of money but on the 50
this is called the rest a leaky day
which is to do with the things that we
agreed to do that we are getting some
benefit from and actually that cost will
be amortized sorry T's a boring word
over could be a long time and I think in
fact the Treasury's going to make it
look much smaller than 50 billion in
order to calm people at you and Nigel
Faraj you also said it's outrageous try
your finger at me in Carol I'm a tree no
I do not you say it's actually Nigel Raj
says it's outrageous I'm just saying the
seventeen point four million people who
voted to Lisa I just remind you that
Michelle Michelle Michelle your concept
the conversation you're leading is
called a price worth paying so I decided
to get my calculator out and find out
exactly what fifty billion pounds might
buy and I thought I'd run you through
some of these it could get you eight
aircraft carriers 300 thousand doctors
2,000 royal weddings 12.5 billion pints
of beer or a night in the jungle with
Stanley Johnson and I know which one I
would go for how many villas in this
hour thousand coming coming back to work
so just just just so don't okay I don't
know if it's fifty billion pounds if it
is fifty billion pounds then we probably
better pay on the on the upside of what
the team to my left is saying if you
were to look at and if it is amortized
over 20 or 30 years actually that is
still a saving of what we would have
paid in to be members of the EU to
support the team on my right I think it
does speak to the fact that we are best
flailing in these negotiations it wasn't
properly presented to the people a bit
like the Northern Irish border and we
are trying to find our way sorry
Michelle is your debate just ripping we
are flailing I just feel everybody we've
all become like amateur economists we
all seem to think we know better than
the people who are currently being paid
to run these negotiations every tweet
variable behind where I am I am fed up
of politicians using it as an
opportunity to score points and snipe
and that's what they have to do but no
they don't what they have to do is go
you know what we if we've collectively
decide
that we are if we've majority decided
we're gonna do brexit then let's pull
together let's work together you can see
they must negotiate for the best deal so
you wouldn't just want David Davis
saying right this is the deal and
everybody saying yeah right you don't
want to unquestionably March behind the
leader do you do want a little bit of
well why don't we try a bit more here
why don't we try to do a show I can't
work out whether I agree with you or not
because I completely agree with you that
we do need to be clear-eyed about this
there are obligations and liabilities
and we're gonna have to pay what we have
to pay however I feel and tell me if I'm
wrong that implicit in what you're
saying is this kind of suspicion that
people are somehow trying to sabotage
the negotiations or trying to make them
more complicated now I think they are
complicated and they're costly and that
was always going to be the I think the
way we are being treated by the EU in
various different parts is absolutely
disgusting I think the fact that they
would not even have like why are you
forcing us to commit to a sum of money
before you will even have conversations
about future relationships why are we
being forced into a corner to say we're
going to give you this before we even
know what we're going to get in return
I know people for example that live in
Spain who are currently being told with
Niger to more than one Airport on more
than one occasion they have to go in
this separate queue when I hear the way
that they are being treated in these
airports by European officials it
infuriates difference how to resume
treated EU residents in the UK still
using a guarantee but also but this 50
billion this is not just this is not
about paying what we owe necessary this
is to open trade talks so it is paying
to do trade which is the ridiculous now
why should we pay today we owe some of
the money yes we also we have given you
yes we do you know what the sum is or
what makes you so outraged about it in
which case the unit may be not very
accurate and fair right and it's going
to open the shop so might actually mean
it me you can leave the EU which is what
you want
if this gets any more than 50 100 or
more while we're just walking where we
keep on banging on about the importance
of a trade deal you know Germany has
it's big its biggest export marketers to
America it doesn't have a trade deal
with America but a trace its biggest
import thinking this the cookies
advisors most from its China it doesn't
have a trade deal why we're sweating
over paid 50 billion for a trade deal do
we all agree we single my yeah it's the
single market forty four percent of UK
exports go to you will not America we
are a small nation do repeat it will be
leave without my exports to the EU are
its master forty five percent of our
exports gauge twenty six percent of our
GDP and if we lost it all if we lost it
all it would amount to one quarter of
one percent of our so you'd be happy to
see our manufacturing industry no longer
able quoting numbers